kawhi and lebron now they
switch here's a screen by zubats and
slithering inside is paul
george marcus morris to that mix
just more length to go against lebron
here comes davis with the hesitation and
fires on the fly
puts it up and in first quarter
something i've noticed is that
frank vogel is putting anthony davis a
lot of times on kawhi leonard that
length nice
quick move there by a.d to get around
noah
quarantine the suspension of play noah
was signed
marcus morris came in that deal here's a
drive by kawaii with a
drive and a beautiful dive for two look
at this move here by kawhi
off the dribble to his left the rotation
is a little bit late there by
javell mcgee high up off the rim
good starters have not made a
substitution yet continuous caldwell
pope on that baseline count it for two
and he's fouled on the play beautiful
give and go here from ad
to kcp
job they've not been healthy most of the
season but they're not
full tonight lebron sneaks it inside for
mcgee pretty pass
by lebron james paul george the other
way
lakers lead nine biggest tonight and it
goes up and in
clippers haven't led this one on the fly
george uses the glass and puts it
through
paul george nine minutes six points on
six shots had trouble finishing
his uh time in miami with uh some
suspensions a drive called well
oh davis
[Music]
wow he had tested positive for
the kovid virus is a nice
timed play here by davis look at the
follow here
here is a shot over lebron by leonard
and a rebound by james
what are you trying to say that lebron
is making all the decisions up in the
front office there captain i think he's
a pretty important
oh
season and look at this i mean this
easily could have been an and one as
well
look at the swipe down there's the
contact he's coming off the bench for
you so it's a huge pick up
for the clippers leaders with a missed
shot nice offensive rebound by howard
finds lebron
in stride for two the out waiters on top
they go for jackson here the clippers
with patterson trying to get free
waiters is on a mismatch good feed to
leonard cutting off that baseline
go to patterson and look at the back cut
there by
leonard and here comes jackson
and paul george last year with oklahoma
city
there's a leonard shot from three here
comes jackson
and paul george last year with oklahoma
city there's a leonard shot from three
leonard's got the ball three or seven
with his start the hesitation in the
13-footer on the fly kawhi
leonard which by the way that's the
first time i've said that
it doesn't feel right does it no beverly
back in trying to get it inside lebron
with the steal
three on two here comes james six points
and five assists
it's paul george who puts in the three
from outside
george with the triple on showcase here
in game one of
this restart danny green makes a move
knocked away kauai got a hand on it and
then is uh
they were going the other way quickly
and it goes to george
a chance to tie here for the clippers
with a three
clippers have never led they've trailed
by as many as 13 kawaii
kauai moments ago yeah but look at the
patience and the fade away
beautiful caruso found open shot clock
at two
davis will take it in with authority
fake giving go here to caruso green
takes the point when he does stuff
when he does stuff you sometimes
marcus morris on top to george little
switch here comes davis now taking
the defense eight to fire three is right
down the hatch
noah here with zubats picking up
his fourth lebron into leonard
[Applause]
boy two guys were right there zubats
went up and leonard was right there the
claw
well we saw the great defense by lebron
at the end of that reels it in here
comes jackson
and off to paul george his triple is
right down
for the clippers here comes green the
cutting mcgee a lot of congestion inside
ricochets free here comes george
uncovered three
bucket nice shot by george
with the shot clock at a try to go
inside the lane which had all kinds of
traffic
scooped up by kawhi leonard
by caldwell pope around james and into
zubox
lebron comes over to help here and
miscommunication javel mcgee a little
bit late
they could use these weeks before the
playoffs to get their rotation set
especially without bradley and rondo
three good kawaii
farm audio is just right there with
javale mcgee his mom was a pretty good
player here's lebron with a three and
that's the first made
shot from the field for the lakers in 14
tries so is in there davis pope and
they've got lebron that's the laker five
beverly drives
two to fire knocked away inside zubot's
got it
shot clock violation brother keeping
lebron out there and
uh james is only three look at this high
and here comes davis down
with a good feed on the play shot clock
at 19 poked it away good play by beverly
throw to let that size and length finish
it
here's cousin with a shot clock at seven
cross court three
davis cod wow another nice shot outside
another three was his 32nd point
he was hitting threes and looking good
doing it came out shooting threes
tonight
waiters the drive kicks it out called
well pope
three davis but he's got another one
[Music]
davis he's got 31 and he puts it in
nice shot and then just face a mid-range
game and using that
length to pull up for the 18-foot here's
pat beverly in the game
not sure how much he was going to play
tonight coming in but he'll put up a
three
caruso late and that's the result of
three by patrick beverly
two minutes gone here in the fourth
quarter lakers clippers dion waiters
triple
bucket nice shot by waiters is this man
in the nba
career high 10 a game for him tonight
with six
across the lane kuzma triple yes
who set that all up though submission
game again your defense is going to be
ahead of your offense
it's kind of showing here with all the
sloppy play 3-13 lebron
cams that one it's a three on the bench
here for the clippers and looks like
he's getting ready to check back in
oh look at george well he took that with
authority and paul's got 22.
oh they're going to call that on dwight
howard on dwight howard
players were looking around like who
they called in on it's on dwight
last season with oklahoma city averaged
28 points a game
three beverly could pat beverly
cams one from three points on 14 shots
that's a three and it's waiters
launching rebound fought for
reeled in by davis out to coos my triple
yes
pretty shot by kyle kuzma
three there's a drive
kawhi dumps it on the wing picked up by
jackson
into jamichael green no foul good
defense by the waker
he's knocked down three triples on top
lebron is there
george splits the d drives leads
nice play by paul george kawhi will
dance kuzma defends knocked away kuzma
good d
george picks it up puts up a three what
a shot by paul
george kawhi will dance kuzma defends
knocked away kuzma good d george picks
it up
puts up a three what a shot by paul
george lebron against green shot clock
at
six no help here lebron puts it up in
town
james is 14 points again
look at the late rotation and if you're
reggie jackson you've got to get up
leonard he has gone three or four from
three lebron will meet him up high
here's george he's gone five of nine
that shot good
it's a three and it ties the game at
101.
nice little step back three here for
pg-13
six threes by paul george four second
difference lebron on the fly got his own
miss
and puts it up and in lebron james
gives the lakers the lead collectively
in this country
two terrific games on tnt going right
down to the wire for the clippers lebron
has got seven in the quarter had nine
the first three quarters
here go the clippers down by two
kawaii's got it
you see the clock lebron on kauai
down to four here's george he's way
outside a lunging three
no rebound caruso that's it
lakers of one the defense by lebron as
well
started on kauai got switched out on
paul george
i mean that's stellar defense there
by lebron
the two best clipper players lebron
james
shuts them both down ali's a six
time all defensive selection lebron
james probably gets
voted there again